let's get you up to speed now on the
statewide ballot questions first off
tonight question one
would give the nevada legislature more
control over the state's college and
university system
this one is still pretty close so right
now it looks like no has the majority
lead at 51 percent a nevada question two
referendum
passed this really had widespread
support enshrining marriage equality
into nevada's constitution with more
than 60 percent of the
voters question three making it so the
state board of pardons meets more often
four times instead of two this
overwhelming at 60 percent
question four enshrines our voters bill
of rights into the constitution
63 percent said absolutely yes make it
happen
question six requiring electric
utilities to acquire
50 percent of their electricity from
renewable resources by 2030
also this one at this point winning
pretty handily at 56 percent of the
voters
eight news now is your local election
headquarters we're going to have much
more election coverage coming up for you
in our next half hour at 6 30.
for the latest results you can find them
anytime though on our website at
8newsnow.com